Nous sommes un matin de 1964,
à l’école Polytechnique.
Les élèves sont réunis pour
un devoir de maths de 5h.
Rien d’insurmontable pour eux,
qui sont des cracks en maths.
Mais au bout d’une demi-heure, ils se
regardent tous : impossible d’aller au-delà
de la 1ère question.
En fait, leur prof leur
a donné un problème impossible.
Les regards se tournent alors vers Attali,
le major de la promo.
Lui aussi est en panne.
Mais à un moment, il se met à écrire : il
règle son compte à la 1ère question ; puis
il passe à la suivante.
Il est comme en transe ; ses
sens ne fonctionnent plus.
Il a l’impression que quelque
chose a pris possession de lui.
Il remet sa copie au bout de deux heures.
Le prof lui mettra 19.
La deuxième note sera… 3.
Jacques Attali est un personnage bien
particulier dans la société française : il
est le représentant le plus emblématique
de l’aristocratie des concours.
Diplômé de Polytechnique, de Sciences-Po,
des Mines, de l’ENA, et docteur en économie
de l’université Paris-Dauphine, il
incarne la technocratie française.
Plus précisément, Attali symbolise le mariage
du savoir et du pouvoir qui fait l’originalité
de la technocratie française.
Son biographe Guy Sitbon le surnomme « le
Prince des concours ».
Après Sartre, c’est un nouveau
modèle d’intellectuel à la française,
moins littéraire, plus scientifique et
financier — en fin de compte, technocratique.
Je vais vous raconter 10 anecdotes révélatrices
sur le parcours d’Attali.
Si vous ne l’aimez pas,
certaines anecdotes vont peut-être vous
faire changer d’avis.
Nous sommes en novembre 1943.
Simon Attali, le père de Jacques Attali,
est en poste à Oran, la ville portuaire
du nord-ouest de l'Algérie.
Il est appelé au front en Italie pour
combattre aux côtés des Alliés.
Il est sur le départ, quand un de ses cousins
vient lui apporter une nouvelle :
« Tu sais ce que tu as eu Simon ?
Pas un garçon. Deux garçons ! »
En effet, Jacques Attali naît
le 1er novembre 1943.
Et une demi-heure plus tard naît BERNARD
Attali — DONC le jumeau de Jacques.
Comme Jacques Attali est célèbre,
Bernard vit dans son ombre.
Mais leur ressemblance
n’est pas que physique.
Bernard, lui aussi, est passé par les
grandes écoles : Sciences-Po, ENA.
Lui aussi fait partie de l’élite
administrative française.
Lui aussi a une expérience au plus haut niveau
(il a notamment été patron d’Air France).
Enfin, lui aussi écrit — des essais,
des témoignages, et des romans —
mais malheureusement pour lui, avec
beaucoup moins de succès que son frère.
Les deux jumeaux Attali semblent proches.
Ils partagent des amis et
travaillent ensemble.
Lorsque les deux jumeaux sont adolescents,
la famille habite au-dessus d’une librairie.
Les clients s’étonnent de voir Jacques et Bernard
partir avec des livres sans payer.
En fait, leur père leur a ouvert un
compte dans cette librairie,
c’est-à-dire qu’ils peuvent venir
prendre les livres qui les intéressent, sans
payer, et lui règlera la note plus tard.
Cette anecdote montre que c’est le père
des jumeaux Attali qui leur a inculqué
la valeur sacrée du savoir.
Il avait voulu lui-même acquérir
des connaissances encyclopédiques :
il avait lu le dictionnaire et une encyclopédie
Larousse du début à la fin.
Mais son quotidien d’entrepreneur
ne lui laisse plus le temps de lire autant.
Il reporte donc son ambition sur ses fils.
Pour leur Bar-mitzva,
— la Bar-mitzva, c’est la cérémonie par laquelle
les Juifs célèbrent l’accession à la majorité
religieuse du garçon à l’âge de treize ans,
donc les jumeaux Attali ont treize ans
— pour la Bar-mitzva des jumeaux,
il leur offre la bibliothèque
ENTIÈRE de La Pléiade.
Après, il ne suffit pas de
lire tous les livres.
En France, c’est le système académique
qui sanctionne le savoir.
Les jumeaux doivent donc être
d’excellents élèves.
S’ils ramènent une note inférieure
à 15, leur père les traite d’«
enfants fatigués de naissance ».
Et il ne cesse de leur répéter : « Vous
ne travaillez pas assez ».
Pourtant, après les cours, les profs
particuliers défilent à la maison.
L’existence entière des jumeaux
tourne autour du travail.
Ce régime strict porte ses fruits : les
jumeaux excellent dans toutes les matières.
Lorsque leur mère veut les inscrire au prestigieux
lycée Janson-de-Sailly, le proviseur
lui dit que c’est trop tard.
Mais après avoir regardé leurs bulletins,
il les accepte immédiatement.
Jacques Attali est en prépa scientifique
— toujours à Janson-de-Sailly — et ses
camarades de prépa n’en reviennent pas.
Lorsque le prof de maths le fait venir au tableau,
Jacques résout la question à la vitesse
de celui qui la connaît par cœur.
Les élèves en perdent la tête.
Ils l’accusent de tricher.
Un jour, le prof le met en garde :
« Vous allez avoir un problème le jour
du concours. Vous devrez convaincre
le correcteur qu’on ne vous a pas
refilé le sujet à l’avance. »
Mais en réalité, c’est bien ce que
fait Jacques Attali : il a déjà
traité tous les exercices !
Il achète tous les manuels, tous les bouquins
d’exercices et d’annales qu’il peut trouver, et il
abat tous les problèmes de maths, un par un.
C’est une méthode qui repose plus sur la mémoire
que sur la réflexion — mais ça fonctionne.
Elle montre que Jacques Attali est très
pragmatique.
Il est ce qu’on
appelle une « bête à concours ».
Jusqu’à sa scolarité à Polytechnique,
jamais on ne l’a vu dans un café, jamais dans
une boum, jamais avec une fille.
Jacques Attali, alors conseiller de Mitterrand,
se retrouve dans le même avion qu’une amie.
Elle lui dit : « Enfin, nous
aurons le temps de bavarder. »
Il lui répond : « Oh oui, venez donc vous asseoir
à côté de moi à l’heure du déjeuner. »
À peine assis dans l’avion, il
déballe livres et dossiers.
Il branche son ordinateur à la prise
de bord et travaille à ses livres.
Jacques Attali est un boulimique de travail.
Comme pour pas mal de gens passés le système
français des grandes écoles, ce qui
était censé être une parenthèse,
un sacrifice à consentir pour intégrer l’élite
académique, est devenu un mode de vie.
Jacques Attali est tout le temps en train de
travailler, d’une manière ou d’une autre.
Il ne dort que 4-5 heures par nuit.
Mais il est plus précisément un boulimique
de lecture et d’écriture.
Il a toujours un livre avec lui,
et il l’ouvre à la moindre occasion.
Lorsqu’il assiste à une conférence,
par exemple, il ne suit que d’une oreille,
pour identifier les idées intéressantes,
parce qu’il est en train de lire un livre.
Personnellement, je ne suis pas certain que ça
soit la meilleure manière de tirer le meilleur
de la conférence et le meilleur du livre.
Mais Jacques Attali est comme ça : s’il ne
fait pas plusieurs choses en même temps,
il a l’impression de perdre son temps.
Jacques Attali a 22 ans lorsqu’il croise François
Mitterrand pour la première fois.
C’est dans un restaurant discothèque
huppé de Paris.
Attali, encore étudiant,
reconnaît le challenger du général de Gaulle.
Il n’ose pas aller se présenter.
Mais sa soirée n’est pas gâchée
pour autant, car il est en galante
compagnie : le jeune polytechnicien
est escorté de Miss France 1966.
Jacques Attali explore le monde
parisien à partir de la vingtaine.
Il travaille certes beaucoup, mais il ne veut
pas être un ermite coincé dans les livres.
Il sait que pour réussir à
Paris, il faut paraître.
Sitôt diplômé de Polytechnique,
il se met donc à sortir.
On le voit dans les lieux prisés,
accompagné de femmes magnifiques.
Il ne renoncera jamais aux mondanités
malgré ses responsabilités.
Des hommes impliqués au plus
haut niveau de l’administration
renoncent souvent à à peu près tout
— mais Jacques Attali, lui, multiplie les dîners,
ne manque aucun événement, aucun concert,
répond aux invitations des journalistes,
et fréquente tous les artistes à la mode.
On peut dire, dans la terminologie de Bourdieu,
qu’après avoir construit son capital CULTUREL,
Attali construit son capital SOCIAL.
Pardon pour l’interruption, mais
j’ai une question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont
lu tous les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne
pourrait pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale,
ce n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas
qu’un seul secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes
les plus cultivés, les profs,
et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT ces cinq
secrets, mais ils se gardent bien d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT
leur culture générale, parce que
leur rapport au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq
secrets, ils comprennent toutes les références
des personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec
profondeur sur n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les
conversations et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour
faire preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment
les appliquer DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS
RAPIDEMENT SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de la
vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui est
dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes,
donc faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
« Je veux être le Raymond
Aron de la gauche. »